This quiz will see if you understand execution time
well enough to make some predictions. So, here's the
code we had before that times the execution of
evaluating a Python expression that we pass in as
code. And we've defined spin loop as a while
loop that goes through a loop that just adds
one the number of times of the variable passed
in. So let's try that in the Python interpreter.
We're going to time an execution where
what we're evaluating is calling spin loop, passing
in some numbers. So we'll try 1,000 first.
And what time execution does is return two
values. The result and the run time. We only want the second one, so we'll index
to get the second value out of the return result, and see that result. So that's
what we get, so it took 0.0001 seconds to do spin loop a thousand. If I increase
this to 10,000, I see that it takes 0.0006. let's try 100,000,
adding one more zero and I see now it takes 0.005. I'm going to write this a
little differently, so we can see it more easily. So now, instead of writing
out a 100,000, I'll do ten star, star, five, which is the same value as writing
out a one followed by five zeros. And for good measure, we'll do ten star, star,
six, which is a million times through the loop, and we see that, that takes 0.05
seconds. So here's the examples of timing loops.
For your quiz, your goal is to estimate
the expected execution time for a value running spin loop where the input of the
loop is ten star star nine, that's one
billion. And you should give your answer in
the number of seconds. Of course it's not
possible to get the exact answer, but you
should be able to get a guess within about 20% of our answer to be correct.